Eh bien, vous êtes très nombreux ce soir.
C'est un plaisir de vous retrouver
ici, au Café des Champs Libres.
J'en profite d'ailleurs pour remercier
dès le départ toute l'équipe
du café pour pour leur accueil.
Et voilà le plaisir
qu'on a chaque mois de se retrouver ici.
Donc bienvenue au Café des sciences.
C'est une rencontre qui est organisée
par l'équipe Sciences Ouest,
le magazine de l'Espace des sciences
que vous connaissez peut être.
Et si vous ne me connaissez pas,
ce n'est pas grave,
vous pouvez le découvrir ce soir.
Donc c'est le magazine
des sciences en Bretagne.
Nous avions consacré
un numéro au printemps dernier
sur les landes et les tourbières.
Voilà, je vous montre la couverture.
Vous pouvez aussi le retrouver
vers mon collègue.
N'hésitez pas à venir le feuilleter
à la fin de la rencontre ou à l'acheter.
S'il vous intéresse,
ça pourra permettre d'être complémentaire
à ce qu'on va se dire ce soir.
Et c'est un plaisir de discuter
de ces paysages,
de ces habitats avec vous, ici
à mes côtés.
Deux spécialistes,
tout à ma gauche, François de Beaulieu.
Vous êtes écrivain, ethnologue et bénévole
à l'association Bretagne vivante.
C'est bien ça ?
Oui, oui, parfait.
Bonsoir !
A vous de vous accueillir
au côté de Sébastien Gougaud
et vous êtes enseignant,
enseignant chercheur
en écologie au laboratoire
éco bio à Rennes qu'on connaît bien.
Ah, c'est bien ça, c'est ça !
Alors, chers publics, vous
êtes invités à poser toutes vos questions,
tout au long de l'échange.
Pour ça, il faut pas hésiter
à lever la main afin qu'on vous donne,
qu'on vous confie un micro pour qu'on
puisse bien vous entendre.
Et surtout, la rencontre est enregistrée.
Donc, si vous n'avez pas de micro,
on ne pourra pas vous entendre
dans l'enregistrement.
Ça serait un peu dommage.
Donc n'hésitez pas à nous faire signe.
Et et après on enchaînera les questions.
Peut être que pour commencer.
Peut être pour comprendre
surtout de quoi on parle.
Je pense qu'il est important
de revenir sur les définitions.
François Sébastien,
est ce que vous pourriez nous expliquer
en quelques mots
ce qu'est une lande
et ce qu'est une tourbière ?
Et peut être leur point commun ?
Est ce que ce ne sont
pas les mêmes paysages ?
Et peut être qu'après,
on pourra développer la biodiversité
que ces paysages hébergent ?
Et d'abord,
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une lande ?
Qu'est ce que c'est qu'une tourbière ?
C'est une définition scientifique, donc ?
Sébastien Oui,
je parlerai pour les hommes.
Les définitions, c'est toujours
sujet à débat.
Donc on peut prendre une définition
et puis s'y tenir.
Et puis après on développe.
Donc une tourbière, c'est
un écosystème qui se développe
déjà sur un sol particulier
qui est fait de matière organique
qu'on appelle de la tourbe.
On est un peu techniques ici, au sol,
donc c'est un sol constitué
de tissus végétaux
qui sont faiblement décomposés.
Et sur cette histoire là, sur cette tourbe
se développe une végétation particulière.
Cette végétation, qui peut varier
en fonction des perturbations en fonction
des climats.
Mais en général, l'espèce
qui nous intéresse
le plus dans les tourbières,
c'est les mousses qu'on appelle l'Espagne.
Donc c'est
une espèce très particulière
qu'on caractérise d'ingénieurs
parce qu'elle est capable de créer
et de produire
des conditions qui sont favorables
à son propre développement.
Ça fait qu'elle élimine les autres
et elle favorise son propre développement.
Et donc elle peut se développer
de manière abondante quand les conditions
le permettent.
Et peut être que j'aurais dû préciser
au début, c'est que les tourbières
sont des zones humides.
Donc forcément, il y a de l'eau,
il y a beaucoup d'eau.
Et si on enlève le caractère humide
des tourbières, c'est c'est
une tourbière perturbée qu'on peut arriver
à faire revenir à sa tourbière
si on la restaure, et notamment
la restauration hydrologique.
Donc voilà, donc je dis les mots
principaux zone humide, tourbe, sphaigne.
Voilà ce qu'il faut retenir.
Donc il y a de la sphaigne.
C'est que si on est sur une tourbière,
pas forcément
parce qu'on peut avoir de l'Espagne
et qu'en dessous on n'a pas de la tourbe,
c'est qu'on considère qu'une tourbière
doit contenir au moins 40 cm de tourbe
et la tourbe doit contenir au minimum
20% de matière organique,
donc 20% de matière végétale
qu'on va bien peu décomposer.
Voilà.
Et la lande, c'est aussi une zone humide,
donc pas forcément.
D'accord, c'est plus compliqué que ça.
Moi, je peux seulement ajouter que
pour les humains
qui vivaient à proximité des tourbières,
la tourbière, c'est même si c'est apparu
apparemment plutôt tardivement.
C'est une zone où on peut trouver
un combustible, à condition de creuser
un peu, de dégager des
et de faire des sortes de pains de tourbe
qu'on va mettre à sécher
pendant tout l'été et qu'on va ensuite
rentrer dans des greniers et qui va
permettre de faire des feux longs,
en particulier
pour des cuissons à l'étouffée
ou pour simplement laisser à un feu
qui s'entretient tout seul
pendant toute la nuit
et qu'on va pouvoir redémarrer au matin
avec une odeur toute particulière
qui est donnée par cette tourbe.
Voilà comment les humains
qui vivaient à proximité
des tourbières définissaient.
C'était une zone de production
d'énergie pour eux.
Et voilà
maintenant pour la définition scientifique
des Landes.
Alors moi je peux, expert des Landes.
Mais en tout cas, les Landes,
c'est de l'écosystème qui se développe
sur des sols qui sont très pauvres,
donc plutôt des sols assez minéraux.
C'est caractérisé par surtout des espèces
d'une famille particulière
qu'on appelle des éricacées.
Donc, si vous avez des jardins où,
vous avez peut être des bruyères
dans vos jardins.
Les bruyères, c'est une éricacées
qu'on trouve abondamment dans les Landes.
Donc on va dire que c'est une zone
peu productive
en termes agricoles,
sur lesquels se développent des bruyères.
Et puis, en fonction de l'humidité,
on a différents types de landes.
Donc on a des landes sèches,
des landes humides.
Et c'est au niveau des landes humides
où parfois on a des choses
qui sont un peu connectées
entre les tourbières et les landes,
parfois selon les des perturbations
que le système peut avoir
ou les conditions hydrologiques.
Une lande peut se transformer
en tourbières et inversement.
Donc c'est vraiment
la lande humide
qui sont des cousines des tourbières.
Voilà.
La lande tourbeuse étant une originalité
bretonne,
une spécificité en particulier
présente dans les monts d'Arrée.
Mais pour les riverains des Landes,
la lande, c'est un espace.
C'était un espace indispensable
à la production agricole traditionnelle.
Une bonne ferme, c'est
une ferme qui avait des landes
en plus des terres labourables
et des prairies.
C'est ce que l'on appelait dans les
ces catégories là.
La définition, c'était des terres froides,
par opposition aux terres chaudes
qu'on pouvait cultiver.
Mais elles étaient indispensables
parce qu'on avait peu de terres chaudes
et que pour produire le fumier
destiné à faire l'engrais
qui permettait d'avoir en particulier
des céréales ou des légumes,
et bien il fallait qu'on ait de la matière
parce qu'on faisait.
On n'avait pas assez de paille
avec les céréales.
Et donc cette matière végétale
qui permettait de faire le fumier
dans les étables.
C'était, c'est les bruyères
et le petit mélange de plantes
qui poussent avec les bruyères,
dont les agents et quelques graminées.
Qui c'est cette litière qui allait
permettre de produire un bon fumier.
On en avait parfois suffisamment, même
pour ne pas tout mettre dans l'étable.
On en mettait dans les cours,
dans les chemins creux.
En hiver, c'était broyé.
Ça, c'est à se mélanger avec de la boue
et au printemps,
on racler tout ça aussi
pour faire de l'engrais.
Donc il y avait une source et une source
particulièrement renouvelable puisqu'il
n'y avait aucun apport particulier
dans les Landes, si ce n'est
qu'elles servaient aussi à autre chose
d'essentiel dans l'équilibre agricole
qui était le pâturage
par le bétail, pâturage plutôt extensif.
Il n'y avait pas de clôtures,
il n'y avait que la bonne volonté
des petits bergers
en charge de surveiller.
Et donc il y avait ces petits apports là,
plus les apports atmosphériques aussi.
Il ne faut pas négliger ce que la pluie,
ce que la neige peuvent apporter. Mais
sur ces terrains
pauvres, on avait cette production
de matières végétales
qu'on pouvait récolter en fonction.
Effectivement du type de landes
tous les 4 à 5 ans,
en par une fauche, une fauche qui formait
des sorte de mosaïque compliquée
puisque vous aviez du coup
quatre cinq auteurs de landes
en train de pousser ce qui est
ce qui était un élément qui favorisera
quand
la biodiversité dont on parlera après
et mai faucher
avec des outils particuliers la faucille.
Un certain nombre
de tranches qui variaient beaucoup
d'un terroir à l'autre.
La faut plus tardivement
et uniquement sur des Landes
où il n'y avait pas de cailloux
de bonne qualité.
Facile à faucher.
Et c'est,
comment dire,
cette
mosaïque n'a
rien à voir avec ce qu'éventuellement
ceux qui ont traversé les monts d'Arrée,
qui est le dernier endroit
en Bretagne
où il y a réellement encore de l'ordre
d'un millier d'hectares de landes fauchées
ces fauchés de manière mécanique
et sa forme non plus des mosaïques
mais des grands damiers.
En fait,
on peut faucher une dizaine d'hectares
d'un seul
tenant d'un seul coup
et avec des balles rondes.
Tout ça est totalement mécanisé,
donc on ces paysages de landes aujourd'hui
qui subsistent,
n'ont rien à voir avec les paysages
tels qu'ils pouvaient être façonnés
par l'agriculture
traditionnelle bretonne,
pour qui c'était un élément essentiel.
Et on ne peut pas comprendre
le fonctionnement de l'agriculteur
traditionnel bretonne sans recourir
à cette compréhension des usages
des Landes
qu'il pouvait y avoir.
Je crois que le décor est posé.
C'est très intéressant et important.
Je pense effectivement de revenir
sur sur cette histoire.
Est ce qu'il y a déjà peut être
une petite question dans le public ?
Madame tout deux,
on va vous donner un micro ? Oui.
Bonsoir, Est ce qu'il est enfin ?
Quel était ou quel est ou quel était
le régime de propriété des Landes ?
Est ce qu'on peut posséder des Landes ou
est ce que ça fait partie des communs ou
est ce que ce sont des terrains municipaux
alors sous l'ancien Régime ?
Dans la majorité des cas, de toute façon,
les Landes appartenaient
soit aux aristocrates,
soit au roi, soit aux abbayes
et à l'Église, d'une
manière ou d'une autre à des abbayes.
Mais à des ordres religieux.
Donc c'étaient,
mais avec des droits d'usage
réglementé et dépendant,
variable selon les endroits, selon
les types de baux qu'il pouvait y avoir.
Vous aviez le bail
à un domaine considérable qui était
relativement avantageux puisque si on vous
le bail était rompu par le propriétaire,
il devait indemniser l'agriculteur
des améliorations qu'il avait faites.
Par exemple,
il y avait d'autres endroits où on était
dans des baux
beaucoup plus durs et sévères.
Et puis il y avait ce qui, c'était
ce qui s'est développé dans une partie
ouest des Côtes d'Armor
et des monts d'Arrée et leurs environs,
qui étaient un système qui s'appelait
la Corrèze, qui était très original,
mis en place en particulier
par les moines cisterciens
et par les Hospitaliers de Saint-Jean.
Cette pratique là consistait
à donner
l'emplacement pour construire une maison,
un journal
de terre autour de 5000 mètres carrés
et de la bonne terre a priori,
et ensuite un usage à des terres
qui pouvaient être soit
qui pouvaient être défrichées pour une,
soit une exploitation en commun
dans les Landes,
soit créer des cultures
et avec des redevances qu'on payait
à l'abbaye en fonction de la récolte.
C'était un pour centage,
ça pouvait être à septième,
20ᵉ, et cetera en fonction des récoltes et
simplement,
ce qui était extraordinaire, c'est
que le Corrézien
pouvait faire
hériter son plus jeune enfant,
même si c'était une fille de sa maison
et des terrains, qu'il avait du terrain,
qu'il avait autour et des droits
qu'il exerçait par ailleurs.
Ça a été un système très égalitaire
parce que chacun avait les
mêmes choses et c'est resté.
C'est un des éléments d'explication
du vote rouge Dans la partie ouest
des Côtes d'Armor
et dans les monts d'Arrée,
où le vote paysan communiste
a été une caractéristique
tout à fait remarquable et continue
à avoir une certaine empreinte
sur la sociologie électorale.
Ce qui s'est passé simplement,
c'est que tout à la révolution,
toutes ces propriétés ont été abolies
au profit en fait, des villages.
Ce sont devenus des communs de village
dans la majorité des cas,
parfois des communes,
sinon des villages, et cetera
On a tout à continué pareil,
sauf qu'on ne payait plus de redevance.
Mais c'est apparu aux yeux de
ce qu'on pourrait appeler pour les.
À cette époque,
le lobby de la grande révolution agricole
initiée par les Anglais au 18ᵉ et
voulue
par une partie de la grande bourgeoisie
et de l'aristocratie bretonne
pour ne parler que de la Bretagne
au début du XIXᵉ siècle.
C'est apparu comme étant un frein
en fait aux progrès agricoles
parce que on
y avait, on ne défriché pas.
Tout reposait sur cet équilibre
entre a priori
des gens qui avaient des exploitations
de même type,
qui avaient le même nombre de vaches,
qui avaient les mêmes usages,
qui, quand ils voulaient cultiver
un morceau de
la langue commune, pouvaient
faire ce qu'on appelle un Buache.
C'est à dire qu'on a arraché les mottes,
on les brûlait sur place,
on étendait la cendre.
On cultivait pendant trois ou quatre ans
du seigle,
du blé noir
et ensuite ça retournait à la lande.
Après, donc, c'était un barrage
qui était un travail collectif.
Mais tout cela était contrôlé
par le groupe social.
Ça fonctionnait très bien.
Bon an, mal an,
il n'y avait pas de famine.
On était pauvre,
mais on n'était pas misérable
et il n'y avait aucune raison de changer.
Mais le lobby agricole
qui voulait le progrès disait
Ah si on avait
des propriétés individuelles,
alors là, les gens travailleraient plus,
les gens cultivaient,
défriché plus de terrains
et donc il faut mettre fin à ces communs
à force de
par divers moyens,
mais en particulier par une loi
qui est passée en 1850,
ils ont imposé le partage des communs
et à partir de là, tout doucement,
on a eu des défrichements, de la mise en
en culture et quand il ne pouvait pas
y avoir de la mise en culture
dans la majorité des cas,
les grands propriétaires qui avait racheté
d'immenses morceaux de communs des plus
célèbres, c'est la princesse Batthyany.
Vous avez peut être traversé à jour
le bourg de Colpo en allant vers Vannes.
Ce bourg est complètement artificiel,
créé par la princesse
qui achète 400 hectares de landes
et qu'il est fait défricher
parce qu'elle a des moyens importants.
Et quand on ne peut pas cultiver,
eh bien on boit.
Et c'est comme ça qu'on installe
ces paysages de pins maritimes
et qu'aujourd'hui, les landes de Lanvaux,
c'est certes un peu de landes,
mais de la lande sous résineux,
parce qu'en
plus ces pins maritimes
se sont ressemer spontanément.
Donc voilà, pour répondre à la question,
c'est resté des communs
jusqu'à ce qu'on impose les partage.
Mais dans certains cas,
et en particulier dans les monts d'Arrée,
les partages se sont fait.
Mais dans les villages,
ils ont dit On est obligé de partager,
on se débrouille, on partage entre nous.
Et puis on continue pareil comme avant.
Et jusque dans les années 50,
il y a des endroits où tous les
tout le bétail des gens d'un village
continuaient à aller
pâturer de manière extensive.
Des parcelles qui en fait étaient,
d'un point de vue cadastre,
attribuées à chaque famille du village.
En fait, mais il n'y avait pas de limite
de propriété bien souvent
et on usait librement.
Mais après, finalement, on savait et
sauf quand on a refait les cadastres,
c'était tellement compliqué
qu'on a tout découpé
géométriquement pour que personne n'ait
a plus qu'un autre.
Et le résultat, c'est devenu ingérable.
Et c'est comme ça que beaucoup de landes
se sont trouvées abandonnées.
Elles n'étaient pas
suffisamment intéressantes pour être mises
en culture et elles ont été abandonnées
dans certains cas,
des gens bien organisés ont pu racheter et
ou proposer des contrats
pour faire des groupements forestiers.
C'est comme ça
que beaucoup d'espaces de landes ont été,
sont devenus des
et des espaces couverts de résineux
et dans d'autres endroits
que les Landes n'ont plus été entretenus
et ont évolué vers des forêts qui brûlent
très bien.
On ferme après.
On s'en est aperçu l'année dernière.
Pour finir, je dirais que simplement,
ça fait qu'on est passé
pour revenir à l'ancien régime.
Fin de l'ancien régime ?
On a globalement 1 million
d'hectares de landes en Bretagne
pour 3 millions d'hectares pour
la Bretagne, cinq départements bien sûr,
1 million d'hectares, landes et et espaces
non cultivés,
mais pas les Landes au sens
strict des botanistes.
Mais on a 1000000 d'hectares aujourd'hui
au sens des botanistes.
Qu'est ce qui reste
comme lande en Bretagne ?
En tout, 14 000 hectares,
dont plus de la moitié,
ce sont les monts d'Arrée
d'où leur importance.
Mais 14 000 hectares, ça peut vous sembler
beaucoup par rapport
à vos 500 mètres carrés de pelouse ?
Ce n'est jamais qu'un
carré de douze kilomètres sur douze,
c'est à dire presque plus rien.
C'est à dire
que chaque lande aujourd'hui est précieuse
est un élément de ce patrimoine ancien.
Et quand je lis dans cette excellente
revue Science Ouest,
un numéro assez récent,
qu'une société qui s'appelle Eco trie
et qui vous vend des arbres
pour les générations futures
dit qu'elle fait des expériences
d'apports de différents prébiotiques
et et autres fertilisants pour vérifier
si ça pousse bien.
Nous avons choisi d'étudier
une seule essence des sapins de Douglas
sur trois parcelles distinctes,
une ancienne culture intensive
de céréales, une autre où avaient cohabité
prairies et cultures de céréales,
et une ancienne parcelle de landes.
Eh bien, je suis désolé,
ces gens là prétendent
avoir une action écologique dès le moment.
Qui décide de boisé ?
Une parcelle de lande ?
Ils font disparaître
un élément du patrimoine.
Voilà,
c'est bien parce que le sujet, c'est
quand même la préservation.
Ce soir.
Et justement,
je trouve que c'est peut être intéressant
de revenir sur l'intérêt de ces paysages.
Alors il y a la biodiversité
qu'ils hébergent.
Ça, je pense qu'on peut,
on peut en discuter.
Et puis je pense notamment aux tourbières.
Mais peut être que c'est
le même cas pour les Landes.
Ce sont des puits de carbone
pour les deux types
de quoi que ce soit pour les Landes,
que ce soit pour les tourbières
ou les tourbières,
ce sont des puits de carbone.
Je pense un peu plus que les landes.
Mais les tourbières, c'est
des écosystèmes qui couvrent à peu près
3% de la surface des continents,
mais ils contiennent près du tiers
du carbone des sols mondiaux.
Donc, vous imaginez vraiment qu'une
toute petite surface à l'échelle mondiale
contient une quantité
énorme de carbone à l'échelle globale ?
Et ce carbone là, qui est piégé
dans le sol et piégé sur le long terme,
c'est autant de moins de carbone
qui se retrouve dans l'atmosphère.
Parce que ce carbone dans le sol,
il vient du CO2 qui a été absorbé
par les plantes, par la photosynthèse
qui se retrouve dans la matière organique
des plantes, dans le sol
et qui ne se décompose pas.
Donc c'est vraiment
du stockage de carbone,
autant de carbone qui n'est pas
dans l'atmosphère et donc les écosystèmes
tourbeux de manière générale,
participent à la régulation du climat
à l'échelle globale.
Et donc, quand on a des usages
très intensifs sur les tourbières,
qu'est ce qu'on fait finalement d'estoc,
ce carbone
qui a été piégé durablement dans le sol ?
On a des stocks
et on envoie dans l'atmosphère
des stocks sous forme de CO2,
donc dioxyde de carbone, soit de méthane,
qui sont des gaz à effet de serre
et contribuent à l'effet de serre global.
En détruisant,
en perturbant les tourbières.
Donc maintenant,
les gens se sont rendu compte,
on fait pas mal de choses,
même au niveau politique européen,
même si on ne va pas assez loin.
Mais par exemple,
on ne peut plus exploiter la tourbe
qu'on exploitait avant en Europe
pour faire par exemple
le support de culture.
Et maintenant il y a beaucoup
d'actions de restauration des tourbières.
Et donc, comme j'ai,
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure,
les tourbières, c'est une zone humide.
Donc la restauration,
ça passe toujours par une remise en eau
des sols qui ont été drainés
et ça peut parfois
amener à des conflits d'usages, notamment
avec des agriculteurs
qui ont pu bénéficier
de ces terres
qui ont été asséchées et sur lesquelles
ils ont eu une exploitation agricole.
Donc maintenant, il y a tout.
Il y a des enjeux autour
de la préservation
et la restauration des tourbières,
non seulement pour le carbone,
mais aussi pour l'eau
et pour la biodiversité.
Parce que ce sont vraiment des écosystèmes
qui sont à la croisée des
des trois enjeux principaux
environnementaux actuels.
Oui, parce qu'ils jouent un rôle aussi
pour la gestion de l'eau.
C'est ça comment ça fonctionne ?
Alors où est donc
donc il y en a parmi vous qui ont déjà vu
une tourbière et même des sphaignes.
Et ceux qui ont déjà eu ça
peuvent vous rendre compte
que les sphaignes,
ce sont de véritables éponges.
Donc ça peut contenir jusqu'à 20 fois
son poids.
C'est quand ?
Vous imaginez un kilo de mousse là ?
De cette mousse
là peut contenir 20 litres d'eau
et donc la tourbière qui en découle.
Enfin,
la tourbe qui en découle de cette sphaigne
a aussi
cette propriété de rétention d'eau.
Donc, quand vous avez dans un paysage
une tourbière.
Vous êtes assuré d'avoir finalement
un endroit où l'eau va
non pas être stockée, mais en tout cas
va circuler beaucoup moins vite
que s'il n'y avait pas de tourbières.
Et ça, ça peut contribuer
à maintenir les sols humides
et ça peut être très utile en cas
de sécheresse, mais aussi en en cas de.
Mais quand il y a des feux, en tout cas,
plus il y aura de zones humides
dans le paysage et plus l'eau
va être va rester dans le paysage
et ça va contribuer à maintenir
des sols humides et à alimenter
les nappes qui sont juste en dessous.
Est ce qu'il y a une petite question ?
On vous donne un micro ?
Bonsoir !
Euh. J'en ai plutôt deux.
Peut être ce serait déjà comment ?
Est ce que la composition microbiologique
des tourbières aussi
est aussi un aspect
définissant des tourbières ?
Et comment fonctionne
pour être un puits de carbone
et voisin ?
Et je sais qu'il y a un certain écosystème
qui bénéficie des feux, peut être annuels,
sur lesquels se préparent
grandissent certaines plantes.
Est ce que c'est le cas pour
les tourbières ou est ce que c'est plutôt
l'inverse ou je sais qu'il y en a de plus
en plus des feux dans des tourbières ?
Mais quel impact ça ?
La première question sur le stockage
du carbone dans les tourbières,
donc le carbone, c'est exactement comme
votre argent dans votre compte en banque.
Plus vous aurez d'argent qui va rentrer
de votre compte en banque et moins
il y en a qui va sortir
et plus vous allez stocker de l'argent.
Là c'est pareil, sauf que c'est du carbone
à la place de l'argent.
Donc ce qu'il faut c'est
arriver à limiter les sorties.
Et dans les tourbières,
la production primaire, c'est à dire
le pompage du CO2
de l'atmosphère pour faire de la matière
organique, est relativement faible
et des fuites,
donc la décomposition de la matière
organique est encore plus faible
comparé à d'autres écosystèmes.
Et donc cette différence fait que vous
allez stocker du carbone tous les ans
et donc au niveau microbien,
vous avez des microbes qui peuvent
être particuliers aux tourbières
parce que ce sont des conditions
plutôt acides.
Donc vous avez des bactéries,
des organismes, des archées aussi,
qui sont spécifiques de ces milieux là.
Mais ils vont avoir de toute façon
une activité très limitée.
C'est pour ça
qu'on va avoir très peu de carbone
qui va être largué dans l'atmosphère.
Donc je sais pas si j'ai bien répondu
à la première question.
La deuxième question,
je ne pensais pas
forcément au feu dans les tourbières,
mais je pensais aux feux plutôt dans
le paysage qui entourent les tourbières.
Donc effectivement,
dans certains écosystèmes,
le feu peut participer à la dynamique
globale à long terme de l'écosystème,
notamment en bien, en éliminant
certaines espèces, mais en favorisant
d'autres qui ont besoin du feu
pour ensuite germer.
Et aussi, c'est quelque chose
qu'on n'a pas forcément en tête, mais
sur le long terme, le feu peut contribuer
au stockage du carbone
parce que le bois qui est brûlé
se décompose encore plus lentement.
Donc le charbon de bois se décompose
plus lentement que le bois
qui n'a pas été brûlé.
Donc, sur le court terme, c'est
dévastateur au niveau bilan de carbone.
Mais sur le long terme,
vous allez finalement avoir un sol
qui va se développer
sur la forêt qui a été brûlée
et une forêt qui va repousser.
Donc au bout de 200 ans,
vous allez retrouver
votre stock de carbone
que vous aviez avant
plus le carbone, comment est stocké
dans les charbons de bois ? Donc
le feu en soi, c'est pas forcément
mauvais.
C'est
surtout l'intensité et l'étendue des feux
qu'on peut avoir
qui sont énormes actuellement.
Et là, ça peut poser problème.
Et dans les tourbières,
on peut avoir effectivement des feux,
mais ce n'est pas des feux
comme les feux de forêt
ou il y a tout qui brûlent.
C'est un feu qui ?
Je ne suis pas expert
combustion des tourbières, mais
ça fait beaucoup de fumée mais
pas de flammes et c'est très très long
à éteindre.
Donc les feux de tourbières
peuvent être très dévastateurs aussi
en termes de stockage de carbone.
Et ça, ça arrive de plus en plus.
Effectivement, Malheureusement oui.
Du point de vue des humains,
il faut savoir que
les Landes, les, les Landes, c'est
un écosystème qui se développait
depuis la Suède jusqu'au Portugal
en particulier le long des côtes.
Il y en a aussi
d'autres types, plus vers l'intérieur.
Mais il y a une Europe des Landes
et que pratiquement partout
dans cette Europe des Landes.
Un des moyens de gestion
qu'avaient les populations
agricoles de ces Landes, c'était le feu.
On avait des feux courants de printemps
pour justement
favoriser la production
de graminées
plus appétissantes pour le bétail.
C'était un élément,
mais c'était des feux dirigés
sur des de manière tournante,
sur des surfaces relativement réduite
et complètement maîtrisé,
mais avec un isolat.
En Bretagne,
il n'y avait pas ce mode traditionnel,
sauf un seul endroit
pour lequel on a des témoignages
le cap Fréhel.
Quand on dit traditionnellement,
c'est même y compris
il y a, il y a eu encore probablement
les derniers usages du feu il y a 80 ans,
et les gestionnaires du
des Landes du Cap Fréhel
ont repris cette activité
traditionnelle, justement pour avoir
une meilleure maîtrise des milieux.
Parce qu'il y a des endroits qui étaient
qui sont non gérables mécaniquement.
Trop de cailloux, d'autres endroits
où ça commence à poser des problèmes.
Pour le bétail qui servait à l'entretien
parce qu'il
y avait des infestations de tiques
et qu'au bout du compte,
avec les incendies, on faisait baisser
les populations de tiques.
Les bétails pouvaient reprendre
son travail d'entretien
et on repartait
avec une dynamique de remise à zéro.
Alors petite
évacuation de certes de carbone
dans l'atmosphère,
mais aussi avec les effets
induits positifs
et au bout du compte plutôt des
des bilans positifs
et les difficultés des incendies,
C'est quand il se passe
effectivement comme ça a été l'année
dernière dans les monts d'Arrée,
sur plus de 2000 hectares,
sur de très grandes surfaces.
Et s'il se développe, c'est
parce qu'on a abandonné le pâturage
et la faute sur des milliers d'hectares.
Et ça et là, on le voit bien, c'est
le bien
Qu'on soit dans un parc
naturel régional depuis 1969,
il n'y a pas eu ce souci suffisant
d'aide aux agriculteurs,
malgré des mesures agri environnementales
qui sont apparues à partir des années 1993
pour maintenir un niveau de fauche
suffisant pour entretenir les milieux.
Et c'est maintenant
qu'on commence à se poser des questions,
mais c'est déjà trop tard
pour certaines espèces.
A priori, le courlis cendré,
qui avait sa dernière population
de tout l'Ouest dans les monts d'Arrée,
a disparu.
De fait, on en aura peut être encore deux
ou trois couples qui vont venir chanter
l'année prochaine,
mais zéro production de poussins
cette année et
une population qui avait
plus de 100 couples il y a 40 ans
et 50 ans et qui était réduite déjà
avant les incendies à treize
couples nicheurs.
Réellement.
Donc des pertes très importants,
mais pas seulement liés aux incendies,
mais aussi à l'absence de gestion
globale des milieux.
Les coalisent ont besoin de l'Ansej
pour nicher.
Ensuite de l'entretien de zones humides
pour alimenter leurs petits, par exemple.
Et si entre les deux,
il y a une route qui passe plus
un dérangement
permanent par des randonneurs ?
Tout le monde aime randonner
dans les monts d'Arrée.
Eh bien, on obtient comme ça
la disparition d'espèces totalement
inféodées Hollande et à l'action humaine
parce que c'est l'homme des monts d'Arrée.
Ce ne sont pas des Landes,
ce n'est pas des milieux naturels,
ce sont des milieux façonnés
par les humains par appauvrissement
des sols,
exportation permanente de matières
végétales et fauche.
Le courlis ne niche que dans une lande
qui a été fauchée l'année dernière.
Il faut donc s'assoira et qu'en plus
il y a un grand morceau d'un seul tenant.
Faut qu'ils voient venir de loin
les éventuels ennemis
pour détourner son attention.
Donc on a toutes ces questions
d'échelle aussi.
Alors une petite lande,
c'est déjà précieux.
Mais il y a aussi ces questions d'échelle
qui font que pour être fonctionnel,
il faut de préférence
des centaines d'hectares de landes
de différentes hauteurs connectées les
unes aux autres pour que ça fonctionne.
Pour la biodiversité.
Merci.
J'ai vu qu'il
y avait une petite main, non ?
Moi j'ai une question.
Vous parliez des monts d'Arrée.
C'est vrai
qu'on en a beaucoup entendu parler.
Qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui ?
Quelle peut être la résilience de ce type
d'écosystèmes ?
Le courlis reviendra peut être,
mais peut être pas comment ?
Comment le paysage peut repartir ?
Est ce que ça ? Est ce qu'il
peut repartir ?
Et si c'est
le cas, est ce que ce sera dans 200 ans
ou on peut avoir un peu d'espoir
et ou est ce qu'on ne sait pas ?
Peut être qu'on ne sait pas ?
Je ne sais pas.
En tout cas pour les Landes,
je ne sais pas.
En tout cas pour les tourbières,
si une tourbière a été dégradée.
Comme je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure, ce qui est important,
c'est de restaurer ce caractère humide.
Donc ça passe par des actions de bouchage,
de drains ou de remet en.
Il faut intervenir ou il faut intervenir
parce que ça a été vraiment très dégradé.
Dans certains cas.
En tout cas, on revient jamais
au système initial
d'il y a plusieurs centaines d'années.
Ça, c'est pas possible
parce qu'on a tellement transformé
le milieu que de toute façon,
on a un système qui est différent.
Mais en tout cas, on a un système
qui retrouve des fonctionnalités,
c'est à dire un mode de fonctionnement
qui est qui correspond
à l'écosystème de tourbières par exemple,
c'est à dire le stockage du carbone,
une flore,
une flore et une faune particulières.
Et puis une action bien particulière
sur le cycle de l'eau, on le retenant
dans le paysage.
D'accord pour les Landes,
c'est la réponse est complexe
parce qu'en fait, tout dépend
de la vitesse de passage, du feu,
du type de végétation qu'il y avait.
Si le feu est passé très vite sur un
endroit où il y a pas mal de litière et où
la banque de graines n'a pas été atteinte,
la résilience peut être rapide.
Par contre,
quand on a une très mince couche de sol,
mais avec des ajoncs
et des ajoncs bas
qui vont brûler et qui vont rester, le feu
va pas courir seulement dans le haut.
Il va rester
présent suffisamment longtemps.
On peut avoir là
jusqu'à le fond de la banque de graines
et ça va donner des zones
où on va se retrouver avec des mousses
qui vont être la seule végétation
pendant des années.
Des années pour laquelle il est difficile
même de donner justement des pas de temps
pour une reconstitution progressive
d'un sol, même très pauvre par la suite.
Donc des cycles complexes.
Pour ceux que ça intéresse,
il y a un numéro spécial de
la revue de Bretagne vivante, Penn
ar Bed sur les incendies,
avec en particulier un article
du grand spécialiste des Landes Bernard,
Clément, sur justement, cette résilience
des Landes après Incendies.
Je vous le conseil. Effectivement.
Juste un compliment, c'est que non
seulement pour les tourbières,
on peut agir sur l'hydrologie,
mais on peut aussi agir sur la végétation
en faisant notamment
des actions de trappage.
Ça correspond
à On enlève la
végétation qui ne favorise pas
le stockage du carbone.
On enlève aussi les quelques
premiers centimètres de tourbe ou
on trouve beaucoup de graines de plantes
qui ne sont pas forcément intéressantes.
Donc on a de la tourbe nue
et on peut après introduire les espèces
qui sont favorables au stockage
du carbone, c'est à dire à l'Espagne.
Donc on peut faire ces choses
là de manière un peu
artisanale et extensive, comme par exemple
on le fait ici expérimentalement
dans les tourbières en Bretagne,
mais par exemple en ans
au Royaume-Uni.
Ils commencent à réfléchir
et ils font des expérimentations
sur des fermes de carbone.
Ils appellent ça comme ça,
donc des fermes de carbone.
Oui, ils font pousser des sphaignes
dans des anciennes prairies tourbeuses
qui étaient des prairies
parce qu'elles ont été drainées.
Et puis il y a eu des amendements
minéraux.
Donc il y retransforme
ces prairies en tourbières
et ils font pousser des sphaignes
pour stocker du carbone.
Donc c'est une manière aussi,
comme je dit tout à l'heure,
on ne revient pas au système précédent.
Mais moins on favorise une végétation,
un écosystème qui stocke du carbone
parce que c'est vraiment ça.
L'urgence actuelle,
ce qui est une question.
Ah oui, on vous écoute.
Je vous remercie déjà
pour l'explication de
C'était une question que j'allais
poser sur la colonisation par d'autres
espèces ligneuses ou molinie
ou autre sur les tourbières.
Mais du coup, j'avais une question
également sur les Landes
et je me demandais ce quels étaient
les principaux ou le principal facteur
qui explique le faible minéralisation de
la matière organique sur les landes sèches
l'acidité.
Je ne suis pas un expert des Landes,
mais je pense qu'effectivement
les litières des végétaux qui se trouvent
dans les Landes, c'est une litière
qui est très difficilement décomposée,
la litière des éricacées,
et ils ont beaucoup de ce qu'on
appelle des métabolites secondaires.
Donc c'est
c'est l'inverse des autres, d'autres
molécules que la cellulose et la lignine.
En gros,
ces métabolites secondaires
peuvent parfois être très difficiles,
non seulement difficiles à dégrader,
mais aussi
être néfastes
à la croissance des micro-organismes.
Donc c'est un des éléments.
Mais la pauvreté du milieu
peut aussi être un autre élément,
en tout cas de
des éléments qui se combinent
pour faire que la décomposition
assez lente
dans certaines landes
est ce qu'il y a d'autres questions ?
Madame,
on va vous donner un micro. Bonsoir !
Merci beaucoup.
Hum. Je peux être.
Vous allez en parlait plus tard.
Mais je pose ma question quel est le degré
d'information, de formation de
de conscience
des agriculteurs en Bretagne
par rapport au rôle
de la lande, de la tourbière ?
Je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
un carré de douze kilomètres sur douze.
Donc il y a peu d'agriculteurs
qui sont réellement concernés.
Beaucoup de landes résiduelles
sont aujourd'hui
pour celles du littoral, en plus
des propriétés du Conservatoire
du littoral
où il n'y a pas eu,
il y a déjà plus d'enjeu agricole
et ce sont des Landes
pour la
beaucoup d'entre elles qui sont ce qu'on
appelle des landes climatiques,
c'est à dire des landes naturelles
qui n'évoluent pas
dans tous les endroits où elles sont
exposées, aux embruns,
au vent, sur un sol extrêmement fin.
Il n'y a pas de.
Il n'y a pas de question là d'entretien.
Ça peut être après.
Ça dépend des expositions
des vallons plus frais.
Des comme ça
ou il peut y avoir de l'envahissement
par la fougère par exemple.
Ou il faut a des actions de gestion,
par exemple en cassant des fougères.
Mais on est passé là
de gestion agricole à des gestions
par les collectivités
d'une manière ou d'une autre,
à l'intérieur,
dans les zones où il y a encore
des landes importantes,
les normes, il y a les mesures agri
environnementales qui peuvent compenser,
mais avec des gros problèmes
qui sont Chaque fois
qu'on a une nouvelle PAC,
c'est remis en jeu.
Parce que imaginez vous qu'il
y a des mots qui font un tout petit en bas
du traité de Lisbonne
et qui font que l'Europe peut financer
tout ce qui est l'alimentation.
Mais peut elle financer la litière ?
Les Landes ne produisent que de la litière
et ne produisent pas des choux
fleurs ou des ou des choses
qui peuvent être subventionnées.
Et donc, à chaque fois,
il y a un bras de fer terrible
où ce ne sont pas
les agriculteurs qui doivent comprendre,
c'est le ministère de l'Agriculture, c'est
le ministère des Affaires européennes,
c'est la Commission européenne. Et
là, c'est fort heureusement porté,
en particulier
par le Parc naturel régional d'Armorique,
qui est l'opérateur Natura 2000.
Pour les monts d'Arrée, où c'est
la principale zone où il y a un enjeu
ailleurs.
Je pense que c'est d'abord
aux collectivités
de prendre conscience
et de travailler avec les agriculteurs.
Les propriétaires éventuels,
quand elles ne sont pas propriétaires,
pour trouver les solutions.
Parce que les Landes demandent
à être pâturées ou fauchées régulièrement
dans la majorité des cas à l'intérieur,
puisque là,
on a une dynamique plutôt de
défrichement et petit à petit
vers des parcours boisés.
Mais on est toujours devant
cette difficulté que si la paille
coûte moins cher que la lande fauchée
pour mettre, pour faire de la litière,
ça ne vaut pas la peine qu'on
on a.
Il n'y a pas de valorisation,
il n'y a pas de filière.
Ce sont des choix individuels.
Alors je vous dirais quelque chose
aujourd'hui, si vous allez dans la partie
la plus fréquentée des monts d'Arrée,
autour de l'antenne d'Europe très du dont
vous voyez de magnifiques landes fauchées,
elles ont toujours été bien fauchées.
Celles là par et elles sont, elles le sont
par des agriculteurs léonards.
Cette litière là,
elle ne va pas dans les fermes d'à côté.
Elle va dans les fermes du Léon
parce que ça fait de toute.
J'aurais presque tendance à dire
depuis des centaines d'années
qu'ils savent que le
ce qu'ils fabriquent comme fumier
avec cette litière là
est extrêmement favorable
pour leurs légumes.
En fait, c'est parce qu'ils ont un fumier
qui a beaucoup plus de tanin
qu'un fumier fait avec de la paille,
et les tanins ont des fonctions
protectrices sur les végétaux.
S'ils continuent à
faire les kilomètres,
à acheter de la litière
sur pied dans les monts d'Arrée,
c'est parce qu'ils savent qu'il
y a un petit secret là qui garde
bien pour eux, qui est intéressant.
Mais ce sont les meilleures Landes.
Ce sont les
là où il n'y a pas de cailloux,
les plus faciles à faucher, et cetera
Et par contre,
les jeunes qui reprennent aujourd'hui
des exploitations,
ils ont plus des soucis d'agrandissement.
Ils ne veulent pas aller
casser du matériel
parce qu'ils ne savent pas plus où sont
les cailloux dans les parcelles à faucher.
Et on a une baisse tendancielle des landes
pour lesquels il y a des primes
qui sont versées pour le favoriser.
Et donc il y a
des très gros enjeux
qui Les incendies ont cet effet positif
qu'on essaie de reprendre la main,
qu'il y a des magnifiques exemples
d'agriculteurs qui font pâturer
des très grands espaces
de landes par des bêtes à viande. Et
voilà.
Mais pour autant,
on parle de milliers d'hectares
de l'ordre de 8000 hectares.
Tout doit pas être faucher, pâturer.
Il y a des landes qui évoluent
très lentement.
Il faut aussi des vieilles landes.
Mais comment dire ?
C'est un travail sans cesse
à recommencer
et des financements spécifiques
qu'il faudra absolument trouver
pour motiver les jeunes agriculteurs
à maintenir ces usages de la lande
comme litière.
Il y en a
qui ont trouvé des trucs formidables.
Je vous ai dit
on fait donc des balles rondes
avec la litière.
Certains prennent ces balles rondes
et ils ont du bétail qui pâturent
les Landes en été et puis des landes
qui ont des prairies attenantes.
Mais ça fait moins de piétinement.
Et puis en hiver, ils les ont sous hangar
et dans le hangar, ils broient les balles
rondes qu'ils projettent
sur leur bétail qui est là
et qui va petit à petit se décomposer
avec et former une sorte de compost
où les bovins, les bovins.
Ils vont être un mètre 50 plus haut
à la fin de l'hiver, dans le hangar.
On va les sortir et ensuite,
avec un tractopelle, on va sortir
ce fumier
pour qu'on mettra sur les cultures
et qui est très intéressant
pour ceux qui l'utilisent en tout cas.
Donc voilà.
Pour vous dire un peu
des éléments de ces enjeux agricoles
et dans vos projets de restauration,
Sébastien
Est ce que vous travaillez
avec les élus, avec les agriculteurs ?
Est ce qu'il y a d'autres acteurs
qui travaillent avec les scientifiques ?
Donc oui, en Bretagne,
les relations avec les agriculteurs
sont assez limitées
parce qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup
de finalement en surface,
beaucoup de tourbières.
L'exemple par contre, qui est
un peu plus significatif ici, c'est le
le parc régional
des marais du Cotentin et du Bessin
où vous avez
des tourbières qui ont été extraites
de tourbières de Both, donc la tourbe
est extraite sur plusieurs mètres
et donc, pour continuer à extraire,
le gérant a dû pomper l'eau.
La tourbière, donc
faire sortir l'eau du système.
Donc on a une tourbière
totalement exploitée, où le niveau d'eau
est bien plus bas que l'hydro.
L'hydrographie environnante.
Donc ça a eu pour effet de finalement,
tout autour de cette tourbière
qui n'était pas extraite,
de mettre en zone sèche des zones
qui étaient préalablement des tourbières,
et donc ces zones ont pu être exploitées
par les agriculteurs locaux.
Et maintenant que l'extraction de tourbe
est interdite, le site va de nouveau être
géré un peu plus écologiquement.
Et c'est le parc naturel régional
qui va reprendre la gestion du site
et le l'exploitant a pour
obligation de remettre des niveaux d'eau
plus haut.
Ça veut dire que tous les exploitants
agricoles
autour qui utilisaient des terres
qui avaient été asséchées
vont se retrouver avec des zones humides,
voire même des zones carrément aquatiques.
Et donc, il y a tout un travail du parc
régional de discussion
avec les agriculteurs
pour voir quelles mesures compensatoires
ils peuvent fournir.
Et il y a un dialogue comme ça
qui s'est mis en place.
Et c'est en tout cas
l'exemple des relations entre tourbières
et restauration des tourbières en Turquie
qui me viennent en premier.
Donc je pense que ça peut
très bien se passer
à partir du moment
où on donne aux agriculteurs
un moyen de subsistance équivalent
à ce qu'ils avaient avant restauration.
Mais en
tout cas, c'est la philosophie actuelle.
C'est vraiment de dialoguer avec les,
avec les locaux, avec les agriculteurs,
pour que ça se passe le mieux possible.
Une petite question en ce moment, ça,
c'est une question
pour les projets de restauration.
Est ce que vous identifiez parfois
que la dégradation est trop importante
et qu'elle est irréversible ?
Et dans ce cas, comment vous faites
pour identifier si ça arrive ?
Et dans ce cas,
qu'est ce que vous faites ?
L'irréversibilité ?
Comme je dis tout à l'heure,
quand on restaure,
on revient pas au système
qu'on avait avant.
Donc quelque part de réversibilité,
je ne sais pas ce que vous entendez
par là,
mais en tout cas, quand, par exemple,
je prends le cas,
je reprends le cas de la
tourbière qui été exploitée.
On va
finir par avoir finalement un grand lac
et dans certaines zones du lac,
on ne va pas pouvoir
vraiment retrouver un système tourbeux.
Mais dans certaines zones,
on va pouvoir faire des expérimentations
de réintroduction d'espèces végétales
qui favorisent le stockage du carbone.
Et là, on pourra.
On pourra retrouver un système
qui stocke du carbone.
Donc je pense qu'il
n'y a rien vraiment d'irréversible.
À partir du moment où on n'est pas fixé
sur un écosystème particulier,
il faut mais faut vraiment se tirer
de la tête, qu'on va revenir comme avant.
Non, ce ne n'est pas possible,
mais en tout cas,
au niveau des fonctionnalités,
on peut revenir à des choses qui étaient
comme avant,
notamment pour le stockage du carbone
et puis pour la régulation des
flux d'eau dans le paysage.
Oui, pour les Landes,
c'est ça.
A priori, on peut dire qu'une forme
qui a été transformée en champ de maïs,
on l'a défrichée, On a apporté
tout ce qu'il fallait
pour faire pousser du maïs.
C'est râpé.
Normalement,
il n'y a pas de marche arrière
pour se retrouver
avec de la bruyère et des ajoncs.
Sauf que.
Sauf que
les Anglais, qui n'ont peur de rien,
qui ont 1 million d'adhérents à la Société
royale de protection des oiseaux,
là où la LPO en France, on en a 40000,
eh bien, ils n'hésitent pas
à reconnecter des Landes
en rachetant des champs de maïs
et en raclant le sol
jusqu'à l'os pour retrouver
un sol, le sol le plus pauvre possible.
Et là, ressemer
de la lande,
on prend des produits de fauche
qu'on va étaler
et ils recréent des landes.
Alors là, mais avec une exportation totale
du sol transformé,
il faut de gros moyens pour ça.
Je dirais dans.
Aujourd'hui dans les monts d'Arrée.
Moi, j'ai eu le plaisir de voir
que des landes
qui avaient été détruites
pour faire des groupements forestiers
voués à l'échec pour certains d'entre eux
parce qu'on n'avait pas les paysans
bretons sont pas des forestiers.
Ils s'en occupent pas bien.
Ils n'avaient pas bien
entretenu.
Eh bien,
aujourd'hui,
il y a eu, il y a des dizaines d'hectares
qui ont pu être restaurés
justement en décapent dans le sol.
Après avoir récolté les épicéas de Sitka
qui avaient été plantés.
On rappelle le sol et on retrouve
la bande de graines qui n'avait pas
été trop bouleversée et on peut repartir
vers du retour de la lande
sur ces zones où le sol est resté
très acide, pauvre et où.
Après avoir enlevé justement la litière
d'épicéas, on va pouvoir regagner.
Alors ce ne sera pas la lande
dans sa diversité qu'on avait
il y a 50 ans.
Mais malgré tout, en matière,
on peut parler là
de reconquête du paysage, quelque chose
de positif et de reconnexion de lande
qui redonne justement.
C'est une d'échelle dont on a besoin
pour un bon fonctionnement,
pour beaucoup de groupes d'espèces.
Ça donne beaucoup d'espoir
quand même d'avoir comme ces petites.
On a notre question
une dernière on vous écoute.
Bonsoir ! Oui, bonsoir.
C'est une question pour Sébastien Gogo.
Vous allez citer un exemple ou deux de
sphaigne qui sont replantés en Angleterre.
Des espèces de mousses
pour les tourbières.
Est ce que ça veut dire
qu'on peut faire ça aussi
chez nous en Bretagne, sur des sites
où la tourbière n'est pas
irrémédiablement perdue ?
Est ce qu'on peut replanter ce type de
plantes qui stockent beaucoup de carbone ?
Et puis, au final,
en avoir plus que du carbone ?
Merci.
Oui, effectivement, on peut le faire,
mais pas de manière aussi industrielle
qu'ils peuvent le faire.
Tout simplement parce qu'on n'a pas des
surfaces de même surface de tourbières.
Donc on peut le faire à petite échelle.
C'est ce qu'on fait d'ailleurs
dans la tourbière, dans le marais,
à côté de Fougères,
où on a fait des expérimentations,
on a mis des patchs de sphaigne.
On espère que ça va
des petits patchs qu'on a pu mettre
vont prendre de plus en plus de place.
Mais en tout cas,
d'un point de vue économique,
les tourbières en Bretagne
ne sont pas assez grands
pour que ce soit rentable quelque part,
mais on peut le faire.
Des gestionnaires de sites peuvent
le faire,
peuvent
s'inspirer de ce type d'expérimentation
pour favoriser la croissance des sphaignes
et donc le stockage du carbone.
C'est quelque chose que vous faites
dans vos projets de recherche ?
Oui, c'est testé
ou non, C'est à petite échelle.
Donc on a des surfaces de 500 mètres
carrés, donc ça fait pas beaucoup
très épais.
Et enlevez les végétaux qui stockent
pas du carbone et on a fait une dizaine
de patchs de sphaignes de 50 cm par 50 cm
en espérant que ces patchs grandissent
avec le temps.
Donc on a eu un type d'expérimentation
qu'on a fait en Sologne
précédemment
et qui s'est avérée très positive.
Donc c'est pour ça
qu'on a refait le dispositif en Bretagne.
Donc j'en profite pour vous dire
que ce site de Landes Marais,
à côté de Fougères,
c'est un site qui est ouvert au public.
Donc vous pouvez aller le voir
quand vous voulez.
Mais si vous voulez, si vous faites partie
d'un groupe scolaire ou autre,
on peut organiser des visites dédiées
au fonctionnement des tourbières et
à leur diversité.
Merci.
On va prendre la dernière question, ça.
Bonsoir !
Merci beaucoup.
Je voulais rebondir.
Vous parliez de reconquête du paysage
par rapport au Hollande.
Mais a vous entendre,
les Landes sont une terre
plutôt cultivée qui a besoin
à chaque fois de l'intervention humaine.
Ça n'irait pas à l'encontre d'un réel
sauvagement
ou d'un libre évolution.
Je vais vous dire, je suis très favorable
à la libre évolution.
Milieux.
Mais on la voit se passer
dans les fonds de vallée.
En particulier, on la voit se passer
dans le cadre de la déprise agricole,
y compris sur des terres agricoles.
Pour ce qui est des Landes,
il nous en reste tellement peu
et il y en a tellement
qui sont de toute façon déjà en libre
évolution et qui vont vers le boisement
par des saules, par des bouleaux
en fonction de
l'humidité du sol, de différents facteurs
que toutes celles qu'on peut encore
entretenir par une gestion agricole,
Il faut le faire.
C'est là où est irremplaçable.
Quelles sont ces deux ?
Depuis qu'il
y a des troupeaux de grands mammifères
sauvages,
puis des troupeaux
de mammifères domestiques
et des hommes qui les fauche,
que se sont créées des communautés
humaines et animales
fonctionnant ensemble,
qui ont fait ces paysages de landes
et leurs spécificités.
Ce serait dommage d'interrompre
cette longue histoire en se disant bon,
on laisse retourner à quelque chose
qui dans le fond,
se passe déjà suffisamment et où on a.
C'est toute cet enjeu,
surtout sur ces milieux pionniers.
C'est pour ça
qu'on va traiter des tourbières justement
pour les rajeunir,
pour les ramener au stade initial,
parce qu'il y a des plantes
qui ne poussent que sur la tourbe
et que pendant des siècles,
le simple passage des troupeaux,
je dis des siècles, des des millénaires,
les passages de troupeaux
d'herbivores sauvages, Les humains,
par leurs usages
divers et variés, ont fait qu'il
y avait ces cycles de renouvellement
et qu'il faut les maintenir
bien bien,
ce sera la belle conclusion de ce soir,
le retournent très vite, mais c'est
un sujet dont on pourrait parler
pendant des heures.
Merci beaucoup à tous les deux
d'être venus.
Merci à vous,
cher public, d'avoir posé vos questions,
d'être venu et d'avoir écouté.
Cette rencontre sera diffusée aussi
sur le site de l'Espace des sciences,
donc vous pourrez la partager,
la réécouter si besoin.
François, vous lirez.
J'ai quand même quelque chose à rajouter
pour vous dire que, à l'heure actuelle,
vous l'avez compris, il y a beaucoup
d'enjeux dans les monts d'Arrée.
Bretagne Vivante achète des terres
pour essayer de favoriser le travail
de jeunes agriculteurs qui respecterait
justement qui aurait l'usage des landes.
Et que donc,
si vous avez des idées de financement
des plus petits aux plus importants,
ça fait partie aujourd'hui
de ce sur quoi
il faut parfois intervenir très vite.
Parce qu'en face,
il y a des gens qui ont des méthaniseurs
et qui défrichent des Landes
pour y faire pousser du maïs
pour alimenter les méthaniseurs.
Et là, on est dans une folie énergétique
qui ne consiste pas à stocker
spécialement du carbone.
Votre message est entendu ?
Merci beaucoup.
Merci à tous et on se retrouve
dans un mois à très bientôt.